cuphead is a boss brush running a game
with a bit of platforming in a whole lot
of absolutely enthralling cartoon
visuals and snazzy music you play as
cuphead a cop who got too greedy while
playing a casino game of dice and lost
his soul to the devil to keep your soul
you're charged with collecting the soul
contracts of all the other debtors of
the devil
we served as the bosses of the game now
without a doubt the biggest poll and
point of notoriety for cuphead is its
art style which is an amazing homage and
recreation of hand-drawn 1930s cartoons
and animation though since its released
the game is also garnered attention due
to how difficult it is I want to take a
look at how this punishing game play
couples with the beautiful visuals music
and everything else to bring about the
fairly unique experience that cuphead
brings a bit of history to the art style
the first cartoon to ever combine sound
and color was fiddlesticks which
released in 1930 it focused on a frog
named flip traveling over static drawn
backgrounds and Luke Lee interacting
with other animals and personified
dancing objects often with many looping
animations everything is exaggerated and
immensely expressive even the piano that
flip plays looking at cuphead we see the
same thing a lot cuphead travels through
the inkwell aisles fighting his way
against personified and very expressive
plants animals humans and alike all over
static watercolor backgrounds and filled
with looping animations the easiest
place to see these are in the walls
during boss fights in between attacks
and in poor crime the shop key while the
art obviously draws people and due to
its uniqueness there aren't many games
that look like 1930s cartoons it also
does sopia's it's very accessible
cartoons were originally a spectacle for
all something to come see and wonder at
without having to critically think too
hard or overanalyze they were a
technological wonder there isn't a lot
to analyze in Fiddlesticks it's pretty
service level stuff which allowed people
of all ages and backgrounds to quickly
find the appeal in it again the same
thing goes for cup hit the surface
appeal is immense as its recreating and
recapturing the magic of the dawn of
cartoons for a lot of people and it's
giving players
the opportunity to authentically join in
that cartoon fund for the first time
now this isn't as crucial as the visuals
in my opinion but the music absolutely
needs to be brought up the soundtrack
for the game is a collection of jazz
ballads with a mix of big band and
smaller groups it's done fantastically
first all the music by itself is catchy
and well done I wouldn't be surprised to
find any of these songs populating the
radio waves of 1930 to 1960 America you
guys are familiar with the Fallout
series I wouldn't be surprised to hear a
lot of these songs on the fallout radio
and even more all of the music is
extremely catered to the game there are
the songs which directly reference
things in the game like don't deal with
the devil which gives the game's
exposition the barbershop quartet or Die
house which serves as King dies killer
theme song but you can tell that a lot
of the boss soundtracks are clearly
designed for the boss stage to example
the boss cagney incarnation moves in an
almost salsa like motion shaking its
arms back and forth while the song
floral fury plays the song is filled
with maracas rapid-fire trumpet in the
collage of Sachs's and drums all
combining into a reoccurring melody
which would be perfect for an intense
fast-paced dance which you could say is
going on between cut head and the boss
the dynamic of the music is shown in the
dynamic of the visuals what you see on
the screen what you hear come together
so that gives an overview of most of the
non gameplay features now I want to
discuss the controls level design and
combat gameplay and then we'll see how
these intersect or don't so the control
scheme of the game is straightforward as
you can see through the short tutorial
there are really only a few options in
the game jumping and shooting using your
special shot and dashing are the main
set there's also pairing which is really
just jumping again and crouching so the
game doesn't involve any complicated
button combinations or advanced
techniques the controls are simple and
accessible in the same way that the
visuals are however the same is not
super true for the actual gameplay but
before delving into that
want to bring AB level design as it's
very determinate of the gameplay as it
is where the gameplay takes place for
the most part level design in Boston
Riina's is both simple and
straightforward
it's either flat ground stationary
platforms or fairly open air the
simplicity of level design allows the
combat to take precedent you generally
don't have to worry about the level
except in terms of how you can use the
one or two features in it to avoid
getting hit the exceptions to this would
probably be the Dragon and the B boss
fights in which the platform seems
somewhat randomly generated so you have
to adapt to that but the combat and boss
attacks in those sections makes up for
it by being pretty simple and somewhat
lethargic and pace if you would have had
stationary ground overall cuphead is
quite a difficult game your first time
through will probably be accompanied by
one to fifty deaths per boss the first
time I finished the game I think I was
at around 400 deaths now I don't think
there's anything revolutionary or that
stand out among the gameplay in the boss
fights or platforming however I do still
think that all of the gameplay is done
very well it's very solid each boss is
extremely visually anthem Attica Lee
distinct but this carries over to combat
I never felt that I was having to employ
old techniques to fight a new boss the
boss levels varied between static
dynamic and always moving arenas the
attacks were usually unique and fitting
to the boss I did say the control setup
is simple but that doesn't mean it's
deployment in the game is as well the
game can get very complex very fast if
you know what you're doing even if you
don't know what you're doing for that
matter playing too risky by moving into
zones in which it's easier to get hit
often reward the player by allowing them
for more damage with different weapons
like the spread shop it also rewards
ability to focus on offense while
playing defense the auto lean tracer
allows you to solely focus on dodging
the bullets will find their target for
you but this comes at a hefty cost in
low dam the dps for the chaser is only
fifteen point six this damage is dwarfed
by the strongest weapon in the game the
charge shop which has DPS of 40 but
requires aiming and delay for every
single shot meaning is a lot easier to
miss and if you don't charge it all the
way you're gonna get very poor damage
this means that a lot of focus is taken
away from Dodge
the game does not have much
customization but the dynamics in weapon
variety
fortunately allow for at least a few
different strategies while fighting
bosses on the solely defense side of
things there is essentially always a way
to avoid getting hit whether that be
through better positioning or being
ready to make a risky - the majority of
deaths will be your own fault which they
have to be or the game could not have
succeeded it's hard enough to get people
to play a game in which you fairly die a
lot it would be impossible to get people
to play a game in which you unfairly
dialogue you'll generally be able to see
what you did wrong and know what to do
better next time though speaking from
experience it could take 20 tries to
actually consistently make that better
move now this complexity and difficulty
is in my eyes very juxtaposed with
everything else the accessibility and
even familiarity of the silly cartoon
visuals and the groove and soundtrack is
at odds with a difficulty and the high
learning curve that the game reveals
this dichotomy acts to engage multiple
faculties of enjoyment while plain the
upbeat visuals and music brings the
player up while the bosses continually
beat the player down I'd say that the
most popular example of a similar
crushingly difficult game in recent
history is the souls franchise which
rather than employ dichotomy between
welcoming graphics and punishing
gameplay like cuphead does fully commits
to the difficulty of gameplay with a
complimentary dark and brooding world
I'm not saying one of these
methodologies is better or worse in
gaming but realizing the difference is
important if we want to understand
cuphead and appreciate it for what it is
I'd even go to say most games take the
dark souls approach of making gameplay
and everything else complimentary it's a
lot more straightforward of an approach
and that really really works Dark Souls
is an amazing series and the combination
of similar themes between gameplay and
audio visuals really hits the overall
feel of the game home the dark world and
ominous music adds to the tough combat
to create a very rough atmosphere and an
almost sinister tone but having a game
that instead puts its gameplay at odds
with other features allows us a
different sort of feeling and enjoyment
cuphead in particular activates not only
our appreciation of difficulty but also
our more silly enjoyment and
Staal juh of things like Saturday
morning cartoons if you know anything
about my channel you know I fully
appreciate the souls approach it lets
developers evoke deeper levels of
specific feelings much more so than a
game like puppet but come pet simply
offers something that is not found as
frequently
fortunately the developers did a very
good job of pulling off this dichotomy
so it avoids a potential pitfall a
feeling shallow in both gameplay and
everything else instead it pairs solid
typical gameplay with more upbeat
visuals music and level design create a
game that lets us experience a wide
range of emotions and enjoyment at once
so that's really my main point in the
video is seeing that other side of
things that we don't normally see in
games but I still have two things I want
to bring up and I didn't really have a
great spot to put them previously those
things are the expressions of characters
throughout this game and Harry the
expressions are really the only time I
think the visuals line up with the
combat and pairing is to me a microcosm
of the dichotomy that I've gone over
some expressions almost every set of
eyes in the game even cup heads and mug
man's are aggressive and combative the
bosses take very menacing looks like
they really want to send you to the
afterlife the way they're drawn makes it
look like they're having fun with the
violence as well this still connects
with the old solid cartoons as animators
back in the day and now definitely would
have wanted their characters to look
like they were having fun to make sure
audience had fun with them button
cuphead this reveling in the fight is
the secluded example of some other
feature lining up to a tee with the
gameplay in combat I think it's a very
well-done exception so lastly I think
pre-fitting is pairing the point of this
video was to look at how gameplay is
juxtaposed with the rest of the game and
cuphead to bring about different
emotions in the player at the same time
pairing represents this and most of how
I've seen other content creators talk
about pairing I think supports this
claim it's always seen as a pretty weird
thing so almost any parable object is
something that can damage you you have
to jump and jump again into the object
that you're rewarded with another
playing card for special moves
you'll and the berries if you fail you
take damage so jumping into damaging
items is a bit unintuitive in the first
place but then to booth every parable
object is pink pink is a kind of a leaf
interesting color choice for this pink
is symbolically a delicate color that
represents things like sweet nice
playful this historically at odds with
damaging projectiles that can lead to
death or put you in a bad position the
positive and negative feelings wrapped
up in pairing are a more clear example
of the same phenomena happening through
the entire game and it's pretty cool to
me
that's why I made the video so that
about wraps up all of my thoughts on
cuphead in terms of gameplay versus
everything else this was somewhat like a
review but not quite since I was more
focusing on I guess I'd say part of the
game it wasn't a comprehensive review I
hope you enjoy it I do want to do more
analysis like this so if you like this
kind of stuff let me know however you
want to and thanks again for watching
have a good day